on all of this house oversight committee
chairman James comr Mr chairman I know a
lot of people have been pushing you and
pressuring you to to call or subpoena
these Witnesses earlier now you had an
initial list yesterday that list has now
expanded to how many people that you
have
subpoenaed well we have uh almost 10
people subpoenaed we've requested
interviews with another 10 and we still
have a few more to go so at the end of
the day we're going to be asking around
two dozen people uh that have a great
deal of knowledge about just exactly
what the bidens were doing and uh who
the people were that were wiring the
money from the foreign countries to the
bidens we're going to be talking to
every one of them and trying to connect
the dots with the evidence we've already
accumulated which is primarily bank
records Le let's talk about the shell
corporations let's talk about you've
identified 10 Biden family members if
you include President Joe Biden that
have benefited financially with dealings
from China Russia Kazakhstan Ukraine and
Romania close to $30
million do we know anything that they
did for this
money not a thing absolutely nothing uh
we all we know is that the bidens
received millions and millions of
dollars from foreign Nationals and from
oligarchs these were people that uh I
like to say were bad people from Bad
countries that were in trouble or
wanting something we saw that with the
case of barisma they were needing a
prosecutor fired who was investigating
for corruption uh we think a similar
thing happened in Romania we know uh a
lot about why he got three and a half
million dollars from Russia we haven't
talked about that yet and we're learning
every day more about the millions of
dollars they they took in from China so
we're looking forward to hearing from
people that were involved with all of
those different schemes Tony balinski is
someone that has been on your show Sean
we're looking very forward to hearing
from him I think he has a great deal of
insight as to what they Biden's lawyer
wants to uh the justice department to
investigate Tony balinsky do you know
why I I don't know but I've heard Tony
balinsky say Bring it on I mean this is
another example of witness intimidation
this is what we've dealt with from day
one I mean if it's not the Biden lawyers
in the White House attacking key
Witnesses it's it's the Biden lawyers in
in in the White House attacking me and
members of the oversight committee for
having the audacity to investigate
public corruption I mean the the amount
of interference by Biden and his
followers is unprecedented in this case
yet we continue to provide new evidence
uh almost on a daily basis of of major
criminal wrongdoing by the Biden family
and at the center of this was President
Joe Biden all right we appreciate your
time James Comer chairman house uh uh
reform oversight uh and account
committee thank hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else